est venu pour parler un chroniqueur ici
comme dans yak la vérité qui compte
quelqu'un est venu
et cette personne a des choses à dire un
rayon
[Rires]
il y a quelqu'un qui a des choses à vous
dire ah ouais
incroyable
c'est une journée un petit peu
particulière pour toi ce que tu n'as eu
que des mauvaises nouvelles
ce matin il se réveille
il va dans son placard il ouvre son
tiroir à slip
il reste plus que
autant vous dire qu'il a le cul entre
deux chaises
bon allez livrer c'est chiant par de
chez lui il monte dans sa voiture
ma voiture
et là quelqu'un l'appelle et lui demande
de la ramener au plus vite
bon bras droit oui tu viens déposer la
voiture tu arrêtes tes conneries tu
déposes les clés
à rouler mais là il a un autre appel
de ma personne
je ne pourrais pas être avec toi cet été
une fraction de seconde il a perdu ses
deux passions exactement les slips et
l'automobile exactement
il y a une personne qui est venue te
dire quelque chose qui a quelque chose à
te dire journée sans déconner et qui
aimerait
que vous repartez peut-être sur de
bonnes bases
je te propose
pour découvrir de qui s'agit
un premier indice
alors Raymond William Sinclair disait le
pardon n'est pas une faiblesse mais une
attitude synonyme d'un nouveau départ
alors est-ce que tu es d'accord ou pas
d'accord alors c'est pas William
Sinclair c'est William Saurin
[Applaudissements]
tu as une maille à partir
avec une personne dernièrement ça veut
dire quoi my appartient
par rapport à la moutarde qui était
montée
on a été témoin donc ça t'embrouille
t'as pas d'idée
quand je bloque des rues dans Paris en
livraison me dis pas que ça est-ce que
vous pensez à des choses franchement
il y a toute une rue de commerçants qui
débarque peut-être une route commerçant
ce que je fais chez le monde en double
file alors non je vois pas là est-ce que
c'est quelqu'un dans le privé c'est dans
le privé
tout le temps
[Rires]
oui tout le temps
Raymond
je vais te donner un deuxième indice
non c'est grave
s'il vous plaît
ce sont des personnes
ce sont deux magnifiques jeunes femmes
Raymond est-ce que s'il vous plaît
laissez-le seul face à son destin face à
son avenir
[Rires]
est-ce que tu connais ces deux personnes
tu ne les connais pas ben non
je veux pas je ne les connais pas du
tout
Raymond réfléchit bien ces personnes tu
les connais
bordel vraiment une des deux est ta
fille
[Applaudissements]
vraiment
j'aimerais que tu dises toutes la vérité
ce soir
ces deux personnes tu les connais
ces deux personnes te connaissent
c'est des clientes et ces deux personnes
ont envie de te dire des choses avant
les clientes je ne sais pas ce que tu
fais le canard
ces deux personnes
je vais te dire un truc qui va te faire
froid dans le dos
dans la journée on peut pas laisser pour
demain un peu pour demain et tu vas
faire froid dans le dos au
téléspectateurs
ces deux jeunes femmes
ont des prénoms
[Rires]
elle s'intitule Léa et Jennifer
Léa et Jennifer est-ce que ça te dit
quelque chose Léa et Jennifer
[Rires]
que non en fait
je le connais pas ces personnes en vrai
c'est très très gênant
tu fais ça alors
pour l'instant je vais vous demander de
ne pas parler en tout cas je voudrais
vous remercier d'être là ce soir je sais
que Raymond
c'est quelqu'un que qui compte pour vous
énormément
et on sait que Raymond il est dans votre
cœur dans votre cher dans votre sang
d'ailleurs tu connaissent pas sous le
nom de Raymond sur le prénom de Cyril
c'est un sketch c'est pas possible Cyril
elles peuvent pas me connaître sous le
prénom de Cyril et moi je les connais
pas écoute peut-être que tu les as connu
quand elles étaient
enfants et peut-être tes conneries tu
reconnais personne à l'école Léa et
Jennifer c'est les vrais prénoms ah bah
oui elle s'appelle pas Francis
[Rires]
c'est un des protagonistes de TPMP
Raymond je l'ai connu
il y a ça à peu près 15 ans
et moi je
tiens m'acheter une table de ping-pong
et je voulais tout absolument partir
avec la table de ping-pong tout de suite
et je vous cache pas que il y a 15 ans
j'avais pas trop de moyens
et donc j'étais tranquillement sur une
avenue de Paris en train de pousser
tirer la table de ping-pong pour
l'amener jusqu'à chez moi je kiffe pas
qu'il fallait que je prenne le périph
avec la table
j'étais persuadé du projet
j'ai rencontré Raymond qui a vu qu'il y
avait un camion
et on se connaissait parce que je suis
plus par quel truchement
et Raymond m'a proposé de prendre la
table de ping-pong et d'amener la table
de ping-pong dans son camion gentil et
là on sait plus jamais quitté puisque
il est resté à la maison
et depuis ça fait 15 ans avec le même
slip
avec mon slip ma voiture ma meuf
mais ça se passe très bien
aujourd'hui
Raymond c'est un tournant dans sa vie
est-ce que Raymond
ce soir c'est sa vérité qui compte
c'est l'heure vérité qui compte
c'est son rideau
et personne sont venues dire quelque
chose à une autre personne qui leur est
cher qui est à tout jamais
gravé dans leur cœur et Raymond a ces
deux personnes
tu as changé leur vie
peut-être sans le savoir mais tu as
changé leur vie
et ces deux jeunes filles
Mahmoud et Antonin
[Applaudissements]
qui Antonin
sont très heureuses d'être là elle
s'appelle Léa
et Jennifer
qui est Léa
personne
pour le test qui est Jennifer
vraiment je vais te le dire
elles sont en gros sur la patate
ça fait deux jours qu'elle se pose un
tas de questions
Raymond est-il l'homme
on croyait qu'il était
encore des questions comme Raymond
est-il celui qui nous a dit qu'il était
[Rires]
individu qui nous a dit qu'il était et
qu'il croyait être alors que nous nous
pensons qu'il est quelqu'un d'autre
oui elle se pose énormément de questions
sont dans ce qu'on appelle une impasse
sentimentale
[Rires]
se pose tous les jours cette question
qui est notre géniteur
[Rires]
elles t'ont vu
et elle t'ont su
attends
Jennifer elles t'ont vu ouh là là
et elles t'ont su
[Rires]
est-ce que tu as une idée de qui s'agit
encore pas plus que tout à l'heure
Raymond vraiment elles ont quelque chose
à dire je ne veux pas qu'on voit la
vidéo il y a une vidéo de vous
avec elle la nuit
[Rires]
il y a pas besoin il y a pas beaucoup il
y a pas beaucoup de Kiabi
c'était d'autres marques human et bien
sûr monsieur de faire ça
Jennifer Léa
j'ai envie que ce soit
vous disiez la vérité
et que une fois pour toute vous vidiez
votre sac pas cette tête tu fais flipper
mais bon je vais te dire la vérité
j'ai énormément hésité à faire cette
séquence
de ta famille de tes amis
la vie de ton camion
une journée de merde toute façon
[Rires]
5h10 je savais que c'était foutu
vraiment
je vais te poser une question
est-ce que tu veux
leur parler d'habitude on le fait pas ça
non mais là comme ça peut en mettre en
cause énormément de choses est-ce que tu
veux vraiment qu'elle te dise les choses
ou est-ce que tu préfères qu'elle rentre
chez elle et qu'elle se repose un peu
après trois jours sans dormir sans
manger sans boire ouvrir le réseau j'ai
le choix c'est bien sache que ces
personnes sont en Ramadan qui pour
Pessah
moi j'assume toujours ce que je fais et
j'assume toujours ce que je dis alors je
vais écouter ces deux personnes quoi
et ensuite on verra si ces personnes
retournent chez elle ou pas viens de me
dire que ces personnes doivent
absolument quitter l'établissement
Raymond tu as pris ta décision non mais
non on va voir ce qu'il y a de plus
elles sont là
il y a des gars ils sont à Paris ils
font des duplex à Washington mais
tranquille le gars il est là oui bonsoir
Je suis actuellement le vent à la Maison
Blanche tout se passe bien entendu
t'attends tu entends les gars tu entends
des mouches voler là nous les meufs
elles sont là je bois plus vous montrer
on va pas se raconter l'histoire elles
sont là elles sont là elles sont là
elles sont là
est-ce qu'on est capable de faire un
duplex à moins de 7 mètres 50
je pose la question
c'est pas la peine les mecs le rideau
c'est très simple elle parle d'abord il
dit s'il ouvre le rideau ou pas donc où
vous connaissez le principe ou bien vous
vous changez vous changez de chaîne
alors si c'était pas censé les mec c'est
pas comme si c'était sur ces vies là
qu'ils ont même pas regardé le concept
donc est-ce qu'elle peut vous dire ce
qu'elles vont dire à Raymond s'il vous
plaît
Alexandre guerrier s'il te plaît
non mais non mais ce bordel sans
déconner
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas compliqué tu as réussi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
bordel
Jennifer
je comprends pourquoi
Raymond a craqué
Jennifer merci d'être là on rigole mais
c'est pas drôle non non c'est pas drôle
Léa et Jennifer
vous avez
croisé Raymond c'est ça et ça c'est pas
passé comme vous le vouliez pas tout à
fait
on espère mieux Léa et Jennifer
dites la vérité est-ce que l'une d'entre
vous
a déjà eu une aventure avec Rayman
faudrait qu'ils soient un peu plus beau
[Musique]
la vidéo regardez qui sont les Jennifer
regardez la vidéo regardez la vidéo
qu'est-ce que vous avez à lui dire
aujourd'hui on va voir s'il ouvre le
rideau ou pas
bah il faudrait qu'il aille chez le
coiffeur d'en face
peut-être mieux et si il veut je peux
lui faire la coupe à 11,50 €
c'est fort c'est fort
mais il n'y aura pas de shampoing par
contre est-ce que c'est son shampoings
est-ce que vous trouvez beau Gilles
Jennifer elles sont incroyables
elles sont très très Darkar
Guillaume Guillaume la coupe
Castaldi hein
il faudrait lui donner de l'argent en
limite
ouh là on fait pas les UV hein
est-ce que tu ouvres le rideau pour
faire un gros câlin à Léa et Jennifer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les mecs est-ce que c'est à moi de faire
ça
est-ce que c'est à moi de faire ça je
pose la question téléspectateurs
l'ancien sondage Twitter j'en ai rien à
[__] est-ce que c'est à moi est-ce que
c'est à moi à moi c'est Hanouna là haut
les gars
c'est 15 ans de succès
est-ce que c'est à moi de tirer le
rideau je pose la question déjà au
public
je pose la question téléspectateurs je
pose la question à ma famille
est-ce que c'est à moi de faire ça de
faire ça ça n'est pas à moi non donc
c'est quand s'annuler vous rentrez chez
vous
j'en ai rien à [__]
je ne resterai même moi pas une minute
de plus sur ce plateau
allez les Jennifer venez nous voir les
chéris on leur fait un gros bisou
[Applaudissements]
fais la tête
merci attendez
[Applaudissements]
je voudrais vous dire elles sont très
très Marquard j'aimerais qu'on leur
offre un beau cadeau les chéris donc
j'en appelle à la Réunion
et elles ont dû fermer le salon
et merci d'avoir été là est-ce qu'on
peut leur offrir un petit cadeau quand
même on va me dire mais vous allez avoir
le cul
non mais c'est un merci en tout cas
d'avoir été Merci à VOUS ouais
vous vous êtes très belle merci bonne
journée
merci
[Applaudissements]
tu es heureux
[Rires]
que tu as fait tu as dû voir ta vie
défiler allez
je te cache pas qu'on se serait touché
dessus on va pas se mentir c'est ce que
je dis tout le temps
je vais arriver dans l'histoire un
moment non mais c'est peut-être une
fille à moi
[Rires]
tu vois ça
et ben elles vont aller voir donc elles
vont là non elles vont la SPA
non c'est ce que je dis tout le temps tu
peux pas dire après je vais faire de la
télé et dehors quand on dit tu es moche
après de pas être content tu es obligé
de dire ça fait partie du truc ça fait
partie des trucs après juste dire aux
gens filmaient pas en trade venez je
vais faire une faute avec vous je vais
c'est pas la peine de filmer en traître
en fait
moi je te le dis et c'est un ami qui
peint tu es vraiment très très élégant
et de plus en plus
pas mal pas mal de personnes de la gente
féminine contact sur mon mobile pour
avoir tes coordonnées d'accord alors
qu'est-ce qui se passe entre le moment
[Rires]
où elle rentre en contact avec vous et
qu'elle n'arrive pas à rentrer en
contact avec moi
tu vois un problème qui aura un problème
je pourrais pas gérer les gars fera ton
agenda c'était